[Music]
so an nyc grad started this business
and uh it's been going very well
she charges up to ten thousand dollars
to name your baby
what
why she's a professional baby namer for
10 grand
10k is kind of on the high end if you
want one of those
good names
you know when you buy something
expensive and it has to be good
so when you have a kid and then you're
like you got one i don't want to [ __ ]
when you buy that name you're like
there's got to be a good name oh so the
price makes it makes you feel like you
got something placebo where you're like
i bought a good name therefore it is a
good but are they like
names that already exist like
yeah and they're like [ __ ] or is
it like she's making [ __ ] up like it
sounds crazy clairvont clairvont
actually yeah like is it like good
pretty good yeah i mean as far as it
says here yeah she generates uh like i
guess the base rate's like 1500 bucks
this [ __ ] uses a [ __ ] [ __ ] like a
little searching generator
the wu-tang one oh that's so funny
your name will be tyler's gambino he
goes fifteen hundred dollars for extra
200 i'll get waka on this nick
you want walking to name your baby extra
200 bruh
actually he tripping he's another 200.
he'll make the name
my boy big nuke is going to hop on the
baby name as well
you don't know if you think about like
if you're starting a company you can
hire like those
people that develop brands and marketing
they could just make a name logo all
that [ __ ] for you so maybe it's kind of
like that you know it's like she makes a
whole wait is there like a whole process
like they figure out like when your
baby's gonna be born it finds their
birth chart or whatever she makes a
pitch deck i think it's all kind of like
bespoke like uh
yeah she'll just like suggest different
names and if uh if the parents have like
a business or something that they run
then to make the baby's name on brand
with everything she'll develop like a jk
news baby
she she does like a branding kit that's
lazy like just name your own kid you
know it's like that's the fun part
though isn't it
you could name them where the [ __ ] you
want
i don't relate to this part but a lot of
people do say it's really hard to name
their kid because they don't want to
[ __ ] it up
yeah but i don't i don't unders i never
understood that but i heard that a lot
really how can you [ __ ] it up i feel
like they go okay so i want my kid to
like uh be unique so i want to get a
unique name but then also kids with
unique names also get picked on in their
early life so i don't want to get picked
on and i don't want to give my average
name because they might end up being
like they're just so many like back and
forth in their mind that they're like i
don't know what to choose i actually
knew knew a kid who might one of my old
friends his little brother when he was
born they named him phoenix
but then i guess like growing up he was
getting bullied so much that they
legally changed his name what's the buoy
what do they call a penis
that's better they legally change his
name to phillip afterwards how do you
bully a kid named phoenix like are you
gonna rise from the ashes today
nice meaningful things like
i want to give them
i want to give them names that'll get
them bullied
like punk ass [ __ ] or something the
money probably she probably puts a lot
of thought in like different angles and
how they can yeah she honestly
he's probably a bulletproof name
what's considered a ten thousand dollar
name though yeah oh do they have any
names
yeah does she have examples of a ten
thousand dollar name yeah no it's
because the the thing basically what
puts the value in it is she takes a lot
of time to kind of get to know
everything about the family what's the
experience yeah and it's kind of like
she really does study like you know what
what means a lot to these channels what
are the pillars what are like the buried
treasures within their like family story
and then we'll come up with a name that
shares kind of the same meanings so it's
the branding package that joe was
talking about but exactly so it's not
really like what what is the hot like
they're not gonna just go oh it's jaden
obviously name it like it's
just their life that's the meaning
behind john obviously can you imagine
going through all that she just goes
it's jaden
what if she was like i have to live with
you for three months you're gonna pay me
ten thousand dollars and then i'll give
you the name after and she just lines
that [ __ ] up all year so she never pays
rent she gets paid ten thousand dollars
every time gives you a basic basic ass
name that's what i think i like stripper
names but i just wish it wasn't a
[ __ ] stripper name like what's a
stripper name like candy destiny
what's a mail stripper name cookie
cookie rhino
rhino
ryder
it's something cool bro imagine we got
rhino coming to the stage
just like a gold or a gray like thong
you got a little horn on it you got a
little horn on the on the banana hammock
i think guy stripper names are like
wrestling names yeah like something with
cyclops bulk hogan
bulge hulkish
remember we went to the uh we went to
the chippendales thing to film the
[ __ ] oh yeah
they did have names on there they did i
wasn't reading them they were like kind
of
considered cool boy names and [ __ ] oh
like that's what they have like laser or
some [ __ ]
only that kid
don't bully phoenix bully [ __ ] lasers
laser phoenix could be a stripper named
too though phoenix is fire that's i like
phoenix they could find any way to bully
like tycoon taika so taika's name is
just this is taika right and then one
day he came home from school and he goes
he goes skyler keeps calling me ty but
his name is [ __ ] skyler exactly but
he was like
but he's like keeps calling me taiki and
i keep telling him it's taika and he
feels sad because they just feel sad
right now i might try calling him skylee
see what happens the next day he started
he's like hey what's up skylee you go
you called me skyler you got it now
they're best friends yeah see
so it's not skylee and tykey and they're
best friends now at that age it's like
they don't even know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about
you just get sad no matter what right
you just discovered being sad you're
like i'm gonna be sad yeah
but it is true like you can just find
any way to bully a kid over his name if
you just are bullying the kid everyone
needs to rhyme my name with dick all the
time dude nick the dick yeah you don't
even have to rhyme it it could just be
the way
my name sounds dumb when you say it like
that people people just call me trick
done i don't know what that means they
call me a trick
i got the most like low low-hanging
fruit of like hey christian are you
christian i'm like like do you go to
church
that's too easy to roll my [ __ ] eyes
are you actually christian huh are you
actually christian it's happening
your [ __ ] again asking you god damn
it faster
man yeah i was actually confirmed
catholic oh so yeah i was annoyed
because i'm like they're kind of right
though yeah
nice it's kind of contradicting yeah i
know i can't get away from it what does
it mean to be a confirmed catholic like
are you unconfirmed until like you gotta
get a blue check
[Laughter]
by the pope
there's like
there's like sacraments that you have to
do so like i think it's just catholicism
that has it where it's like you get
baptized then you have like first
communion then confession and then you
get confirmed you gotta go an octagon
there's a whole like yeah with the youth
pastors yeah
you gotta fight a couple of devils you
know you got yeah you gotta like gotta
do some exorcisms and [ __ ]
i did that
i did that [ __ ] when i was like 13 years
old
yeah my mom yeah my mom made us like go
to this like church school me and my
brother like every weekend we just sat
there and just like [ __ ] around and
then we had to get baptized so you're
confirmed catholic as well yeah did you
do the [ __ ] mesh screen like yeah i
jacked after my sister's friends oh you
never did that competition
yeah you had nothing to confess no
there's no [ __ ] wall no like we have
to look at him and be like i did this
this this
so you get to see his reaction to
everything he was he like
oh you're dirty what's the crazy thing
you confess to the
i confess i got horny to mission
impossible too
it seemed like the lasers
impossible he was so close to the floor
participation the the girl from mission
impossible too was so hard who was the
girl i heard zoe saldana or whatever
i don't remember what scene was it
let's find it just type in mission
impossible to girl it must be so fun to
be a priest because like you could get
with your other pre-zombies and just
laugh all [ __ ] oh it's dandy newton
from she's from like uh westworld now
let me see what is fandy
now that's a [ __ ] holy name you gotta
make fun of that chick also adding who
the [ __ ] is before a name always makes a
pleasure
that's a perfect name to make fun of
sandy yeah newton
this is it's her
she's in
man i really hope i get all the sins out
the way if i miss one it's like useless
because apparently you have to confess
to everything or else it's pointless and
i'm like why because if you miss one
it's like ah [ __ ] i forgot i gotta go
back you have to go into detail like
when you said it was mission possibly
were they like which woman
[Laughter]
he just goes
the screen you just see the screen kind
of bend in he's like this would you have
said if you're like i got horn in
mission impossible too and he goes there
were no boys in that movie
now you must confess to lying
[Music]
you